paul mccartney's playing that stevie  wonder caught a microphone that was  falling which makes people think stevie  wonder was not really blind i think  that's gonna create you know what we  what would be the i watch him walk  through a being pretending to be blind  he's like this piano thing's not working  out but if i couldn't see not having i  mean i think you can get out of  conversations a lot yeah yeah see him  just run and then right when he gets to  that door he goes all right hold on hold  on hold on  and then they go  and he just walked into it once he goes  i'm ready to go  and stevie lifts up and winks at us yeah  i love youtube videos like this  yeah using imovie  fade in  jerry soundfield's there yeah this is  one of those big  oh  oh that's that he hits his head on the  microphone so stevie would have heard  that mm-hmm  and then he just all he does is he he  doesn't grab it he just holds his hand  outside  yeah by accident yeah